one celebrity's clever way to attract
support for the people of ukraine if you
follow soccer legend david beckham on
instagram you might have noticed some
posts like this
[Music]
beckham lent his social media accounts
yesterday to the head of a ukrainian
maternity hospital in
kharkiv harkeev i'm sorry
she told his
127 million followers think about that
guys that's over a third of the entire
population of the us about the horrific
conditions her patients have faced since
russia
media to invaded
beckham also asked his followers to do
what they could to support the cause
including donating to unicef he is a
long time unicef ambassador as many
people know
last week another big name arnold
schwarzenegger asked his followers to
tell russian citizens the truth of what
is happening in ukraine the action hero
is hugely popular in russia
yeah i think that's such a smart way to
do it to get the word out especially to
the russian people who aren't getting
the word right the truth right so any
way they can put the truth out so bravo
to arnold and and to david yeah it's
shining a light and some dark corners
right and it's a message to other
celebrities out there exactly use your
social media for good you can be a force
for good and the digital activism is
having an impact